what's certain is that innovations and
investments in science and technology
are the engines of tomorrow's economic
growth that's a certainty if we don't
recognize that fact certainly other
developing nations do so the extent to
which we restrict our own investments in
our own future our own technological
scientific future is the extent to which
we will no longer be players on the
world economic stage so one no longer
has the luxury to think of science just
as something that scientists do that
keeps them entertained you need to
recognize it as that which separates
nations that that advance in their
culture in their economy and their
security in their in their health and
nations that recede so I'm to whatever
extent monies are reduced when they
could have been higher I'm disappointed
in what that trendline might be it's
which Oh an absence of foresight that is
so desperately needed right now